nikola hat mich gezwungen hermann hesses
ja ich habe mich gezwungen hermann hesse
zu lesen weil ich habe total verstanden
warum ich als jugendliche dieses buch so
erfand ich habe schon auch so einen
leichten hesse deckt alles ab was mich
interessiert das sprachlich ja wirklich
ergreifend das ist wieder mal so ein
buch wo man beim lesen merkt warum man
warum ich auch lesen und für manche
sachen vielleicht auch ein bisschen dick
aufgetragen vorgekommen manche
schilderung vielleicht etwas zu
sentimental
es hat campos ja aber das finde ich
wirklich wenig halt der ironischen stil
mehrere chronisch ist es überhaupt nicht
und das gefällt mir einfach gesagt was
hätte gewiss nicht es ist er ist nicht
sperrig es ist nicht aber er ist auch
nicht mühsam ihn zu lesen ich bin nicht
manchmal ist er ein bisschen zu wenig
aber die eben nicht das ist halt eine
geschmacksfrage also ist es die
geschichte von narziss und goldmund das
sind zwei freunde nazis ein mönch und
goldmund ist quasi sein freund und
schüler und goldmund geht dann hinaus in
die welt um diese wirklich zu erfahren
all ihren guten und schlechten seiten
und kommt am ende seines lebens wieder
zurück und trifft auf nazis und dann man
will ja nicht alles verraten kommen sie
also sozusagen als freunde wieder
zusammen
ich bin das ist und du bist gehör das
wäre noch eine andere diskussion weder
sprachlich liegt mir hesse sehr und ich
finde dass es theoretisch und anrühren
und jetzt darfst du nicht mit den augen
rollen
entweder man mag es oder man mag thomas
maag philipp hat über thomas mann
provoziert aber nichts geht über thomas
es stimmt das auch aber ich habe auch
thomas mann als ich teenager war lieber
gelesen weil er mir näher am leben ist
in der darstellung seiner figuren das
heißt mehr als leser wird mehr
möglichkeit gegeben meine eigene deutung
der welt noch mit einzubringen aber mehr
leute lieben hesse war hesse
identifikation gelesen werden kann man
kann auch sagen plakativer kann man auch
dann ist es immer die für heute sage ich
natürlich ist das plakative auch etwas
was dann in gewisser weise auch
angenehmer zu konsumieren ist ich sage
ja nicht dass es ein schlechtes büros
ich sage einfach in seinen
charakterzeichnung ist es mir zu
typisiert
und mir ist es auch von seiner ganzen
struktur her zu festgelegt es ist für
mich nicht lebendig genug es hat aber
das finde ich dann gespräche innerhalb
der die figur ganz endlager hin und
hergerissen sie sind schon konzipiert
natürlich stehen sie für einen
prinzipien es wird immer mit
ambivalenzen gearbeitet es war natürlich
muss man dieses buch gelesen haben
2009/10 lesen sie hesse ich sag euch
hesse wird wieder groß rauskommen
[Musik]